[音楽]
[拍手]
えっ私からですね今日はスイングからアクション行動の起こし方について話をしたいと
思ってます
日々考えていることがあると思いますどこどこ行きたいなーとかどういうことをしたい
なとか色々あると思います
でただそれはやらないとまあ始まらないと思ってます
なのでシンクからアクション行動の起こす校
を起こすって言うところのきっかけになるような時間になれば嬉しいなと思ってます
よろしくお願いします
まず皆さんに質問です
あなたのモットーはなんですかあのぜひ頭の中で考えてみてください
もっとっていうのは座右の銘だったりだとか
大事にしている言葉のことです
浮かびましたか
ok ですかはいでなぜこの質問を聞くかというとあの今回私と皆様ほぼ初めましての
方が多いと思うんですけれども初めましての方でもあのその方のもっと大きくとですね
その方がどういう人なのかとかどういうふうに生きてきたのか後どういうふうに今後
生きてくんだろうっていうのがですねなんとなくイメージできるん
ですはい私のモットーはですねこれです
no time for へじでーしょんですあの女あってる暇なんかないっていうの
が私のモットーです
ノータイムは時間がない一ステーションはためらうとか躊躇するっていう意味です
なので濃淡フォーヘアーステーションで迷ってる暇なんかないっていうのが私の
モットーです
いつ死んでも後悔ない人生を送ろうと思って日々生きてます
まあたとえあの辺からですね打たれたとしてもまぁなんかもう悔いなく行けます
でえっとなぜこのノーテンフォーエステーションに至ったかというとあの私の好きな
言葉のうちの1つに
ガンジーの言葉がありますすいませんちょっとずれちゃってますねえと人間は思考の
産物にすぎない
人は持ってる通りになるっていう言葉ですはいこれはですね私大学2年生の時に出会い
ました
でどう
いう風に解釈したかというと人間は思考の産物ということは多分人間っていうのは考え
てる範囲内でしか動けないんじゃないかなっていうふうに思いました
例えばですねこの写真を見てください
これ何だと思いますかえーっとこれはですね
あのが嫌な共和国というブラジルの右上辺りにある国前ですねあのピライーバという
人食いナマズを釣った時の写真ですめちゃくちゃ重いとかて原案っていうふうに上げて
います
このピライーバがですねこの穴損が嫌な共和国っていうところで取れることを知ら
なければ私はこの国に行くことがありませんでした
知るよしもなかったですが嫌な凶悪に行くっていうふうに怪魚ハンター達に言われて
ですね
床っていう風になったんですね外な曲知ってる方
すごいです何があったんですかっていう
はいありがとうございます
でこの写真を通して言いたかったのはですね人っていうのはやっぱり選択肢を知らない
とまぁほど動くことを行動する事っていうのが難しいんじゃないかなっていうふうに
思いました
んなので思考の幅っていうものをもっともっと広げれば行動の幅っていうのは広がり
ますしより人生が豊かになるんじゃないかなっていうふうにそんな風に当時思えます
たそこからですねバックパッカーだった理由が降ったり
インターンシップだったりいろんなことをしました
日本で育つと結構常識に囚われたりだとか
固定観念にとらわれて抜け出せないっていうのが結構あるかと思います
で私も皆さんと同じように日本で生まれて私はね県四日市市生まれです右脳のリスがち
ですはい
同じように育ったんですけれどもまぁちょっとしたことがきっかけで留学行った中国
行ったり
振り返ったりなんで行ったりいろんなところに行くようになりました
いろんな経験を通してもう何事もあの楽しめるようなマインドになりました
ちょっとこのグラフを見てください
これ知ってる方いらっしゃいますか
これはですね感情曲線というふうに言います
左この辺はですね生まれた頃でここは今ですはい
で上の方は嬉しいとき下の方は悲しい時とか悔しい時辛い時を意味しますは私の場合は
誤りからゾーンとしているんですけれどもこれは8ちょっとですねいじめの経験になり
ましても知りたいって思うような毎日を
送ってましたでその後は大工だったりドラムだったりいろんなポートを通しても
ハッピーになって最近だと創業前ですね
会社を作る前にズドーンと落ちた経験があります今日はこの
創業前このあたりのことにフォーカスをして話をしたいと思います
私は大学卒業後東京に行きました
東京で就職活動をして就職活動を支援するような会社とか採用を支援するような会社で
営業活動してました
でものすごく1年目頑張りまくりましたで2年目に新規事業を作りました
海外事業部ですねバックパッカー営業って言ってですね
バックパッカーシップから海外を営業するようなスタイルで
8 e 炭事業を始めました
で自分たちで会社会社じゃないですね事業を作ると自分達サービス名を決める
授業内容を決めるあとは事業の方向性を決めるだとかいろんなことを自分たちで決め
ないといけませんでした
んなのでどんどん愛着も持っていきます
ですしあのいろんなユーザーさんもたくさん良い方々が集まってすごいいい方が林の
見てきましたですごい楽しかったです
この写真はベトナムに行ったときにあのユーザーさんだとか
駐在員の方々現地の方々はいろんな形ばを集めてイベントをした時の写真ですこの後ろ
にはいろんな
まだ340人くらい人がいるんですけれども本当に最高の日々を送ってたんですね
いろんな本当にあの良い人たちに囲まれて幸せだなっていうふうに思ってました
ただその最高が本当に最高なのかなっていう思う日がきました
それはですねあるイベントに行ったときのことです
えっとこのイベントはいケーキベンチャーと呼ばれるような社長さんたちがまあ対談を
しているようなイベントでした
私はですねこれ運営スタッフだったので今回はの後ろにいらっしゃる方々のように後ろ
の方で
あのこのイベントを見守ってましたで話を聞いていました
ます
その時に思ったのがこの人たち本当にかっこいいなっていうふうに思いました
なんでかというとあのスピード感が凄いはめちゃ速いんですよね
スピード感持って授業をしていてインパクトを出していて世の中に良いことを出してい
て皿でちゃんと事業を成長させてるっていう話をたくさん聞きました
私ちょっと自分のことについて考えたんです
じゃあ自分ってどうなんだろう
っていう風に考えました
自分はやっぱりまだまだ全然だしあのスピード感も遅いしちゃんとインパクトも出せて
なくてこれだったらなんか
自己満だなっていうふうに思っちゃいました
なので私の最高だなっていう思いは自分の枠の中
思考の範囲内で止まってたんだなっていうふうに気づきました
そこからは会社を辞めて会社を立ち上げるのかそれとも会社を継続させるのか赤い者と
いう授業をですねそのままその会社に残って継続させるのか
色々悩みました
挑戦をしてスピード感を持って新たな道をつくっていくのかそれとも安定した旧がを
もらって
大好きの仲間たちとすと一緒にやっていくのかいろいろすごい悩んでこれ grand
ground グラグラしてました
ただですねあのやるってこー1回いうとですね
どんどんなんかその噂が広がってって自分が思っている以上のスピードで周りが進んで
いくんですね
ウェブサイト安く作れるとかあるよとか何か鉄道カーとか私泣いて全部せてきました後
かあの色々とみんながサポートしてくれましたああそうすると色々と責任か
思えてくるのでしかもやるやる詐欺は本当によくたいので
じゃあ会社を作りますというふうにあの企業に向けて進めていきました
ただその中でもですねやっぱりいろんな葛藤が上となります
果たして私に出来るんだろうかとか私はあのまあ会社の企業とか経営とか
まあ全く私わからなかったので本当にやれるのかなと
みんなすごい簡単簡単って言ってくるんですよたださ
その簡単だけじゃないじゃないですかみたいな感じで言ってて
え私でいいのかなってなりましたこのまあか
4に続けて給与を回ってやってたほうがいいんじゃないから結婚とかしちゃった林
ジャイガーとか色々覚えましたはい
ただですねあのまーすってついて来てくれる子もいるので
がんばろっと思ってたんですがある日ある人から
ある質問をいただきました
それは
きくちゃんは誰を幸せにしたいのっていう風に言われました
その時私はですねたぶんすごいもういろいろ悩みすぎてあのその質問に数が答えられ
なくなったんですね
誰を幸せにしたいかということすらもう答えられないなんて本当に腹が据わってない
なーと思って
すごい悔しい思いをしました
ただと同時にこうも言われました
ピクちゃんはきくちゃんでいいんじゃないっていう風に言われましたはいこれを聞いた
ときはびっくりしました
きくちゃんであることがうらやましいよっていう風に言ってくれました
その時ですねまじびっくりしてあのあそうかと私は何か
社長はこうじゃないといけない例えば社長ってなんか強くないといけないイメージある
じゃないですか
とか社長って全部把握してこういう風な方向性を全部示さないといけないだとか
なんか社長はこうてなり内でいけないとか企業はこうでなければいけないというふうに
勝手に思い込んでたんですけれどもなんかそんなに勝手に強がってても私はこういう
性格って皆知ってるのであの強がってても意味ないじゃんとアホらしいなっていうふう
に思いました
はいなのでもう私が苦手なところは相手が強いところでもあるので
じゃあそれをあの得意な人に任せちゃおうと甘えていいんだって言う
ふうに思いましたそこからですねすっごい楽になってあのカ国は決まりました
でこれ言われた時にですねあの
そんな中途半端な気持ちだったら絶対企業なんてしないほうがいいと
絶対に失敗するかやると方がいいっていう風にも言われたんですねめっちゃムカつく
じゃないですか結構ショックというか
あの悔しいんですけれどもと同時にこれが波乱スゴからかって思うほど腹の底からです
ねやりたい
いっていう風刺起こったんですねやりたいやりたいって思って
なので起業しましたはいえ私はまぁそうやって覚悟を決めてから1ヶ月後に東京して
さらに1か月後に会社をスタートさせました
新たなまぁ大好きな仲間たちが集まって今一生懸命みんなで頑張ってます
私が何をしたいかというと者リーダーを作りたいなというふうに思ってます次世代
リーダーです
でそれはどういう人かっていうとあのお金持ちとかキャリアキャリア的に成功している
だとかそういうのがリーダーだんじゃなくって皆さんに強み弱みがあると思うんですね
私にも強み弱みがあるように皆さんにもそれがあると思います
はいでその強みを最大限生かした上で自分はこれだって思うような分野で輝く人が
もっともっと増えていったらいいなと思いました
そういう人たちが100に集まったらたとえばここにいる人がみんなそういう
リーダーシップを持ってたとします
そうするとたぶんこの周りにいる人はそういう人たちがまた100人200人いると
思いますしそういうリーダーし
と思った人たちがたくさんいるとたぶん100年先も200年先もそのリーダーシップ
っていうの残っているかもしれないと思うんですね
はいでさらに私はお祭り状態をつくりたいと思ってます
あの地元でお祭りがあるとどういう気持ちですかちょっと想像してもらってもいいです
か
なんかちょっとピーヒャラピーヒャラ聞こえてきてなんかどういう気持ちになりますか
私はですねあの高揚感が湧いてきます
なんだかよくわからないけれども高揚感が湧いてきてそこに行ってみるとなんか知ら
ない人も知ってる人もいるけれども a とかって言ってあのどんどんどんどん
話し合って言って共通項を見つけてじゃあここいくとかこういうことをやってみないと
かそういうのをなんか生まれるのがお祭り状態
だと思っているんですねそういうようなエネルギー値が高い状態のコミュニティとか
パーとかを私は作り出したいなというふうに思ってます
じゃあ会社を立ち上げてどうだったのか
会社企業とか会社を作るってどういうイメージを持っていらっしゃいますか
余裕だよって思ってる方もいらっしゃるかもしれないですが結構効くのはですね
太平そうとかなんか畳3畳で暮らせるんじゃないのとか借金地獄じゃないのとかそう
いうのがイメージされると思います
じゃあ私はどうだったのかこれです
人生でこんなに楽しいことってあるんだって思うくらいめちゃくちゃ楽しかったです今
も楽しいです
まあ日々更新され続けてますはいでえっとこの写真はですね創業時の写真なんです
けれども
まあないこととかできないことが当たり前なんですね
それが作らないといけないのでそれが大変ではあるんですけどもまぁその
歴史を一つ一つ作るのがすごい面白い感覚です
と同時になんか色々今までってここにいたら椅子があってあるのは当たり前ステージ
あるのは当たり前だと思うんですけれどもこういうのも全部自分たちではないといけ
ないので当たり前のことって一つもないんだと思ってあのすごい感謝でしたはい
私はですね人生はジェットコースターのほうがいいと思ってます
あの結構ウネウネしてるんですけれどもこの下の方のネガティブな要素だとか
変化をすることって結構嫌がられる対象だと思うんですね
ただ私が思うにですねあのゼロ付近の事ってあんま覚えてないじゃないですか
あの皆さん人生を振り返ったときに結構覚えてる事ってなんかめちゃくちゃ悔しいとき
とか悲しい時とかちょうだいた時だとかめっちゃうれしいといえばとか
まあその+号とか-5の方が覚えてると思うんですねであればあの子のプラス5-5を
いかにとっていくかっていうのが結構大事なんじゃないかなと思ってます
あの人生100年時代って言ってらっしゃいましたけれども本当に高校生でも大学生で
も40歳でも50歳な
何歳でもこの変化っていうのは大事なんじゃないかなと思います変化が止まったらそこ
で終わりなんじゃないかなと思ってます
で今どういう時代かというと私は個人最強時代だと思ってます
どこに属しているかじゃなくってどういう人かのほうが大事になってくる時代かなと
思ってます
どこどこ銀行に何年勤めてどういうポジションでっていうのが評価されるのではなくて
あなたがどういう人でどういうことを思っていて何をしたいのか何ができるのかという
方がまあ大事な時代なんじゃないかなと思ってます
ん
m a b c d て色々あったときに昔は a しか取っちゃいけなかったと思う
んですね
終身こうやっても死語になりつつあるかもしれないんですけども
昔は a しか取っちゃいけなかったことも別に a と b の高合わさるところを
とってもいいですし
そこに c を入れてもいいし全然違う d も作っていいと思ってます
今はですね別になりないをしたいとかって言ったら切腹とかそういうのはないので何で
もしていいと思ってます
はいなのでまぁ人生はデザインできるっていうふうに思います
じゃあどうやって行動するのかというと私は2つ穴を持ってきました
一つ目は私の好きな言葉ですねモットーです
no time for a day しょんで迷ってる暇なんかないです
大体あのもう皆さん人生いろいろ積んできたと思うのでお分かりかと思うんですけれど
も
だいたい悩んできたこととかなんか迷ってることって後々振り返ると大したことないと
思うんですよ
私もですねあの会社を作るには実は1年間かかりました
no time for a station かといってるんですけど1年間かかり
ました
ただ今考えるとあの時間すごい
無駄っていうか無駄ではないんですけどもなんかエイヤーでやっちゃえばよかったなっ
ていうふうに思いました
なので皆さんもまあ何かを迷ったり考えたりすることがあれば一定時間考えることは
大事ですが
者5分で小原せようとそこからもエイヤーで決めてしまってくださいはい
二つ目はこれです誰を周りに置くかです
誰を回りよくかで環境が変わってくるので耳に入ってくる情報
目に入る情報が全部かあります昔はの facebook の時に友達いろいろ変える
と帰るというかあの増えると全然フィードが変わるんですね
それと同じで誰を周りに置くかで自分の当たり前が変わると思います
私の場合はですねあの起業する前は起業家たちがある周りにいっぱいました
なので起業することが当たり前挑戦することがありも安達太良山へ変化することが
当たり前っていうふうになりました
昔ですね昔というか聞いたことあるかもしれないですが自分の友達の友達の体型が自分
の体型とか自分の友達の友達の休養が自分の給与に近づくとかって聞いたことがあるか
もしれないです
なので誰を周りに置くかでどんどん自分の未来は変わるんじゃないかなと思います
私いろいろ経験してきたんですけれどもまあエネルギーがじゃあどっから湧いてくる
かっていうとやっぱりいろんな経験からだと思うんですね
これを経験しなければ私が今やりたいこと8見ている世界観だとか自分が何が好きなの
か何が嫌いなのかってやっぱりわからないですなので原体験というのは重要でドン
どんどん行動していた一派の続けたいなというふうに思います
だから no time for へステーションで迷ってる暇なんかないで挑戦し
続けたいなと思います
皆さんにも挑戦してほしいですし私も挑戦し続けます
はいで[ __ ]からアクションです思考の幅をいかに広げるか
えっとかハートかって思うほどあの思考の幅広がると思っています
なのでみんなであの未来を一緒に作っていければなと思いますではご静聴ありがとう
ございます
[拍手]
[音楽]